Brian and Lauren are with us hey guys
how are ya
welcome welcome so you're here to do a
debt-free scream yes I know and where do
you live
we're from Greenville North Carolina
absolutely very cool how much debt have
you paid off we've paid off about
$36,000 in 10 months way to go
making what kind of money about a
$90,000 annual income very good good so
what kind of debt was this $36,000 what
do you buy so a lot of the debt was mine
it was a car
student loans from undergraduate and
graduate school and then our baby okay
so mine how long have you all been
married three years day three years Dave
jump right in there
no I love it good yes that's very good
good husband all right so three years
and you brought some of this into the
marriage is what you're saying Lauren
right right it was from school and we
bought a car right before we got married
when we could not afford it so that's
where that came from okay cool so tell
me the story what happened ten months
ago so we've been debri since June so
it's been a little bit longer than ten
ten months yeah eleven so I was spinning
my wheels trying trying every scheme and
gimmick out there to reduce the debt
safer retirement we had this baby so I
wanted to start saving for college but
there was just no money at the end of
the month to do that so we tried a
no-spin September and that didn't work
because at the end of the month Brian
got free tickets to Carolina Panthers
game so that was really exciting but
nothing there's no such thing as free
and that trip ended up costing us 300
bucks
and that was my I've had it moment that
free trip the car parks great experience
Dave but I had to deal with the
repercussions on the way home tickets I
enjoyed it but yeah those hamburgers
aren't cheap and their menus love it
very cool so you you I've had it then
what happened
so after that I've had it moment I read
Total Money Makeover started listening
to the podcast kind of went all in on
the Dave Ramsey movement because your
name is always cited in blogs and
articles everywhere but nobody was
telling me why I needed to get out of
that and then so when I went to the
horse's mouth I finally understood why
we needed to get out of dead some say
it's not the mouth but yeah okay cool so
the the podcasts and the and the book
got you gave you a path my first now
what did Brian do when you go cuz you go
whole hog I can tell you go all-in when
you do something so Brian's like oh god
what's going on I do but I really
trusted this one here yeah she was
really the workhorse in what started all
of it and I've got to give credit where
credit's due and at first I was not a
skeptical person about it but I was
really submissive with that hey you're
gonna spend this or going to spend that
we're gonna pay off this I fell off that
it wasn't until about halfway it maybe
1/4 way into it I saw how motivated she
was which got me motivated in turn I
guess I saw it was working exactly
exactly some of those small smaller
student loans are starting to get paid
off and once you see those loans with
with double zeros across the triple
zeros across the board that's a good
feeling that kind of mode yeah Mesa and
I wanted to knock out a car loan that we
had recently gotten and it eventually
turned into everything else that we had
so yeah started with her good very cool
very cool congratulations you guys so
when people find out you paid off thirty
six thousand bucks in ten months which
means you were doing it I mean you were
beans and rice rice and beans you
weren't gizelle intense without a doubt
right when they find out you did that
they ask what are the keys how did you
do this tell me how to do it what do you
tell him my biggest thing was I had to
look at the proverbial man in the mirror
because I used to nickel and dime this
one big time and I was actually the
biggest offender of kind of blowing the
money and spending on silly stuff like
for the house or stuff like that
what was your worst place that the place
you went that was just really bad when
you did that what you have a targeted
dictionary well I wouldn't call it an
addiction but yeah I would buy a silly
stuff at Target so that was a big one
like stay out of the stores and then you
find out how much you don't need what
you thought you needed baby stuff what
do you think is on sale and then it's
kind of hard to say no and she'll admit
one of the more guilty er persons all
yeah so that was the biggest thing you
have to have that emotional this debt
free process has been so emotional for
me and the budget is another key and I
love the cash envelopes because I've
tried to use the debit card here and
there but once I stopped start using
that plastic it's like oh it like starts
to get away from me so the envelope
systems if you're not using them they
really really work good for you
very cool Brian what do you think the
keys were other than finding Lauren
well again trying to leave Nashville
with a good husband award teamwork
really is what I've learned halfway
through like I said earlier it was
really the biggest component especially
in a marriage she was on board she was
you know spearheading in it and it took
me a little while to get on board and
once I was on board with both of us on
track with this we were able to knock it
down a lot quicker
and it made me understand I mean I'm
stupid when it comes to percentages and
everything so when we hold our Budget
Committee meetings I'm more involved I'm
asking more questions I'm making out
more suggestions and I really think
teamwork is probably the biggest thing
to Factory and when trying to pay off a
bunch of debt Lauren you're a go-getter
but when Brian said he was when he
actually emotionally and logistically
got involved how did that change the way
you looked at him it changed it just it
kind of gives you another level of
respect I've always respected him for
his support of me but you think you have
a good marriage and then when you do
something together it changes the whole
dynamic of it like when you're talking
about saving for your baby's college and
retire
and what your future is gonna look like
it changes the whole outlook and it just
makes me respect them even more than I
did before that's cool
beautiful well done you two
congratulations I'm so proud of you
thank you it's awesome very cool how's
it feel you don't have any payments it
was great
it's great but the house is next and are
coming for us you'll see it's in a
couple more yeah we're coming for you
mark yeah I love it that's cool
Fannie Mae watch out all right Bryan and
Lauren Greenville North Carolina $36,000
paid off in 10 months making 90,000
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream let me go three two one
got you - very well done I love it I
love it I love it that is how it's done
right there folks
without a doubt